[Música]
revista de prensa en directo a América
de Francia 24 y rosa Pérez Mateos con
nosotros en el estudio Rosa bienvenida
buena mañana de martes y vamos a dedicar
toda esta revista de prensa a Jackson
los cuatro meses de protestas anti
gubernamentales en Irán también
desatadas a por la muerte de la joven
kurdo iraní maxa mini el pasado 16 de
septiembre bajo custodia de la policía
de la moral exactamente Buenos días Raúl
y recordemos que las protestas de hecho
empezaron al día siguiente el 17 de
septiembre en saqués en el kurdistán
iraní la ciudad natal de maxa Mini
cuando varias mujeres empezaron a
quitarse los pañuelos de la cabeza y a
gritar muerte al dictador Y desde ahí
empezaron a extenderse estas
manifestaciones a lo largo y ancho del
país dando lugar a un movimiento
antigubernamental masivo protagonizado
como decíamos sobre todo por mujeres y
por jóvenes y desde entonces a lo largo
de estos cuatro meses el movimiento ha
estado marcado
de forma definitiva por la represión
mortal que ha ejercido precisamente la
autoridad iraní Así es rosa precisamente
vamos a empezar entonces repasando todas
estas cifras de la represión con radio
free europe y público exactamente vamos
a centrarnos en dos artículos que nos
dan algunas cifras a no de en Cómo se
cuenta Esta represión según la
organización Human Rights activities
news agent que siempre va contabilizando
los números de fallecidos en Irán se
contarían 522 personas aquí han muerto
en el marco de las protestas de las
cuales 70 serían menores 68 miembros de
la fuerza pública por otro lado 20.000
personas habrían nacido detenidas desde
el inicio de las protestas en septiembre
Y actualmente 15.000 estarían bajo
custodia policial por otro lado pesan
cargos que podrían Conducir a la pena de
muerte sobre 110 personas sin embargo
realmente han sido 17 personas
condenadas a la pena máxima y Irán ya
ejecutado a cinco de ellas Rosa y cómo
ha afectado esta represión al movimiento
es en lo que aborda lo que vamos a ver a
continuación el reportaje la
corresponsal especial en Irán de la
televisión pública de Estados Unidos
estamos hablando de Jane Ferguson
efectivamente que para pvps hizo un
reportaje analizando un poco el
escenario que deja esta mortal represión
en Irán empieza el reportaje de la
siguiente manera en Irán las familias Se
reúnen para llorar a sus muertos a un
ritmo cada vez más rápido a medida que
el régimen intensifica la represión
contra los manifestantes y habla
particularmente de los dos jóvenes
ejecutados en la horca el pasado sábado
7 de enero Mohamed medicarami de 22 años
y se yet Mohamed joseini de 39 quien
fueron condenados a muerte por
supuestamente haber matado a miembros de
la fuerza pública y distintas
organizaciones de defensa de los
Derechos Humanos señalan que los juicios
de estos dos jóvenes fueron una farsa
basados entre otras cosas en confesiones
que se obtuvieron bajo tortura no y
precisamente estas ejecuciones digamos
cumplen con el objetivo de atemorizar a
la población no y precisamente por esto
las protestas después de cuatro meses se
han apagado en ciertas grandes ciudades
a pesar de que continúan activas en el
kurdistán iraní rosa y digamos Cuáles
son las esperanzas de los iraníes que
hablan en este reportaje por un lado no
hay algunos a que confiesan que la
represión funciona como una estudiante
de la Universidad de Teherán que declara
haber sido arrestada tras protestar por
la noche violada torturada y golpeada no
y señala que las protestas en las
universidades son cada vez menos
frecuentes denuncia también el estado de
vigilancia total tanto con cámaras en
las calles como con espías también en
las calles o en las clases de las
universidades un médico del kurdistán
también destaca como ir al médico es
peligroso lo que hay algunas
manifestantes que mueren sucumbiendo a
sus heridas Por el miedo de ser
detenidos en el hospital o que para los
médicos también es peligroso incluso
atender a ciertos manifestantes el miro
de usai también hace un retrato de la
situación o sobre todo enteral la
capital de ese país Rosa Qué expresión
tienen las protestas en estos momentos
bien Pues precisamente en la capital los
jóvenes señalan a que en estos momentos
están llevando a cabo protestas a
pequeña escala como gritar consignas
antigubernamentales en los tejados por
las noches o pues pequeñas
manifestaciones en ciertos campus o
actos de desobediencia civil como no
llevar el velo y que llevan a cabo estas
pequeñas protestas mientras esperan que
el movimiento vuelva a amplificarse a
nivel de todo el país sin embargo las
generaciones más mayores consideran que
ya es muy difícil que el movimiento
vuelva a [__] la amplitud con la que
contaba en septiembre octubre no que
tienen poca Esperanza después de ver
cómo han acabado movimientos antigu en
el pasado precisamente un polito luego
iraní que prefiere mantenerse en
anonimato señala cuando los movimientos
sociales bajo sistemas dictatoriales
enfrentan presiones insoportables
Generalmente entran en una fase de
suspensión Y esto es lo que estaría
pasando en Irán en estos momentos y ya
para terminar en Irán International
también hablan distintos académicos
iranís que dicen algunos describen el
movimiento como un movimiento de mujeres
una Revolución cultural y una lucha
contra el fundamentalismo religioso
otros ponen el eje en el cambio
generacional y en cómo los jóvenes han
perdido el miedo a la represión sin
embargo coinciden en que es muy difícil
que la situación sea como sea vuelva a
como estaba antes de septiembre Rosa
como siempre Gracias por toda la
información toda la información mañana
con más de revista de prensa Gracias y
nosotros pasamos a saludar